china's ambitions in space received a
boost over the weekend as three
astronauts docked at china's
semi-finished space station tiangong is
expected to be fully ready by the end of
the year but china's ambitions don't end
there there are plans to collect samples
from asteroids by 2025 launch a manned
mission to the moon by 2029 and explore
jupiter among other missions the
country's space program has accelerated
under president xi jinping and the
message is clear the sky is not the
limit
three of the biggest celebrities of the
moment in china
two veteran taikonauts and one rookie
were greeted by waving flags and
military honors before their sunday
morning launch time
the scene similar to those for the
soviet union's sputnik cosmonauts and
american mercury astronauts in the 1950s
and 60s
all deemed heroes by their governments
[Music]
the chinese are playing catch-up but
they're blasting through decades of
progress and gaining ground in a hurry
the dramatic launch of the rocket long
march 2f from the edge of the gobi
desert was seen by millions
within seven hours the crew aboard the
rockets shenzhou 14 capsule was docking
with the center part of the space
station which taikonauts are due to
complete by the end of the year
we've entered the core module and next
month we'll see the arrival of wentian
and later the mengtan laboratory modules
we'll then complete the construction of
our own space station our home in space
china's future home in space underpins
its ambitions to become a space
superpower alongside the united states
and russia it's already become the first
country to land a rover vehicle on the
far side of the moon and a rover on mars
i hope the communist party of china and
the people can rest assured about our
six-month mission
china is building its own space station
because it's excluded from the
international space station
that mostly due to u.s pressure on its
partners the american-led iss is likely
to operate until 2030 and after that
china's space station could well be the
preeminent laboratory in low earth orbit
and joining me now for more is dr mark
hilborn from king's college london he's
a lecturer in the defence studies
department and has written about china's
space program dr hilbon what is the
ambition you think that's driving
china's space plans i mean is it
strategic competition or a pursuit of
science
um i think we could argue it's probably
a mixture of both and that's probably
not unusual for any nation really
there's value in conducting purely
scientific endeavors these could be
general of general value in themselves
but they also help build cooperation and
understanding between states
there's commercial value there's a lot
of money to be made in space we're
seeing a you know the commercial sector
now is worth 400 billion dollars
globally and growing
um but also military uh that's another
uh
goal quite obviously one of the troubles
with space is dual use technology makes
distinguishing military and non-military
functions very hard
um so we can probably argue that it's a
combination of all of these things
and through closer cooperation with
other states it can then
increase its diplomatic sort of
influence in
establishing and shaping uh global
governance for instance something we've
seen happening there's a lot of
discussion at the un
uh the uk recently tabled a
a recent resolution this is the result
of
diplomatic good standing and it
generates further good standing so china
will be looking to do probably all of
these things
but how much does china space program
actually help
china at least in the civilian sphere of
things
well there's a number of functions now
that you know we see
utility from in terms of both civilian
and commercial aspects of space
commercially there's money to be made
quite clearly from all kinds of things
like ground mapping and communications
but that can add um
to the quality of life generally
in terms of
you know the average chinese citizen
um
there's there's diplomatic uh domestic
diplomatic agendas too it helps i think
increase the position of the ccp within
in china's citizenry
um
generating that
position and justification for the the
communist party as well so there's a
number a number of domestic reasons
international political reasons but also
military reasons um as well we think
about the benefits in terms of operating
in space
right you spoke about dual use
technology in terms of both civilian and
military uses
of of space is that what particularly
concerns countries when it comes to
china potentially also because of the
lack of transparency uh when it comes to
china's space plans
there is that so inherently space is
dual use so everything from launch
vehicles the satellites to the the data
and services they create can be used for
both audiences
and as you say
it's very difficult to understand what
china's objectives
actually are it's rather opaque in terms
of its decision making so that dual use
element is quite problematic when we're
looking at space generally and
identifying what says military and what
is not military and very particularly
problematic when we're looking at china
so that is that does raise concerns
space is a very sensitive area um for a
number of military and non-military
reasons and so if any
actor is operating in space without
any sort of form of transparency that
creates a lot of concerns um generally
you spoke about uh cooperation with
other countries is that really happening
with china space program i mean for
instance it has been excluded from
cooperation on the international space
station
that's right traditionally china in
terms of military and non-military
aspects hasn't benefited from alliances
such as nato or the five eyes alliances
so it has been somewhat isolated in many
respects in that way in terms of space
though we're seeing increasing
cooperation with russia
now that cooperation goes back to the
soviet era the beginning of china's
missile and space program has a lot of
soviet um dna but increasingly we're
seeing cooperation in two specific areas
with russia and that's in the global
navigation satellite system so clonus
and baidu
and also ballistic missile early warning
um and there's there's a there's a
certain synergy to be created there
um if we think about so the glonass
system has slightly better coverage in
the northern hemisphere china is
slightly better in the south
by creating ground stations in each
other's countries they can increase the
resilience and accuracy of some of their
signals
similarly too that that reciprocal um
ground stations can benefit ballistic
missile early warning and russia is
committed to helping china build a
space-based missile warning system
putting sensors in space
so i think you know we often see china
as having the greater technological
know-how in space and maybe more
generally but we can't forget that
that russia has a great deal of
operational experience in space and so
there's
very fruitful areas of cooperation there
but it is as you say quite limited in
terms of china and that's it doesn't
have that outreach that say the u.s or
western states have
right we live there uh for today but
thank you so much for joining us on this
dr mark hilburn from king's college
london thank you so much